is it food or is it use Crocs or
whatever
kendall Jenner bites into a croc and
some other shoes while playing a game of
food or not food with Jimmy Fallon yours
looks like a real estate yeah the 23
year old model was a guest on the
Valentine's Day episode of The Tonight
Show where she hilariously guessed
weather inanimate objects were food or
not okay mr. potato
[Applause]
okay guys it's an exam I need to count
it down take a bite
3 2 1 boy full dream come true Kendall
is there promoting the new season of
Keeping Up with the Kardashians and
dished on what fans can expect - I hope
so we will have season 16 if Ryan ones
do what's happening this season lots of
I don't know lots of fun things there's
a lot of babies yeah
and drama which you could always expect
pretty much but more so recently the day
before Valentine's Day and her Tonight
Show appearance
Kendall was spotted out holding hands
with boyfriend and NBA star Ben Simmons
after a romantic sushi dinner in NYC
Kendall looking casual chic in an
oversized black leather coat and cropped
jeans she paired the look with furry
black high heels while been rocked a
black sweatshirt black ripped striped
jeans and matching Nikes with gold and
platinum accessories
[Music]